the European Parliament has voted to
declare a climate emergency lawmakers
hope the move will send a powerful
signal to the UN climate summit which
starts in Madrid next week they're also
aiming to put pressure on the incoming
EU executive to take a leading role in
the global fight against climate change
all right let's get more on the story
now we have our correspondent Garrett
Mata standing by for us in Brussels Hank
they are good to see you how much
support was there for this declaration
among lawmakers in Parliament so me a
clear majority here amongst mep
lawmakers in strasbourg backing that
largely symbolic resolution and that was
one of the main concerns for some mep s
who have said you know it lacks a bit of
substance there's that there was the
concern that to extend it could fuel
expectations that then could not be met
and that is why the conservatives for
instance said let's rather call it an
urgency rather than an emergency now
well the majority of that house has now
decided that Europe is the first
continent to speak of an emergency in
case of the climate well some are saying
that this declaration actually does not
go far enough
we spoke to Green Party lawmaker
Phillipe Lambert's before the vote let's
listen to what he had to say the
scientists are basically telling us that
we wasted the last decade in terms of
climate action which means that now the
measures that we need to take a much
more stringent instead of political will
to do that it's very nice to have a
declaration on the climate emergency but
if actions is not following this is just
hot air and while we have enough of hot
air at the moment
Gared that is a concern that a lot of
climate activists certainly have I mean
how will this actually be implemented
that very much them now depends on the
new European Commission and the new head
of the European commissioners Olaf
underline has already announced that she
wants Europe to lead that fight a bit
against climate change she wants to make
it a top priority of her new commission
to fight climate change and that is why
she has put forward a European green
agenda where she wants to make concrete
proposals exactly what mr. lumbers here
is demanding in order to fight that now
I remember very well 2007
tene when the European Union launched a
directive to abolish inefficient vacuum
cleaners and in order to save on on co2
emissions and the result back then was
an outcry across Europe where people
said look this is too much bureaucracy
too much interference so it is
difficulties she is in a difficult
position and making these things from
Europe rather than in within the
nation-states of the 28 EU member states
it is it will be very challenging
it certainly is now very much on the
agenda for the European Union how do you
think climate activists are going to
respond to this declaration first
reactions I have received here in
Brussels is that they do welcome the
fact that now the European Parliament
has acknowledged how urgent the matter
is the house is on fire is what what
creepies for instance said and they
they're glad that mep have now brought
forward that resolution but they made
clear like mr. Lambert's has said look
we need concrete action we need
investment in infrastructure for buses
more trains rather than cars which are
the greatest emitters of co2 in the EU
so a lot of actions if this remains an
empty gesture and that is very much the
feeling amongst the climate activists
who are expected to be on the streets in
tomorrow in Brussels again if this is an
empty gesture it'll do more damage than
good DWS gehrig matters reporting for us
from Brussels thank you very much